Hypothesis testing about the true population correlation is a type of t test.
It uses the t distribution, and therefore, the t table that we discussed
earlier. This is the formula, but you don't need to use it. And the degrees of
freedom are N minus 2. You can understand this intuitively because we have n
values, n for each variable, and we subtract 1 per group. We just wanted to
show you this so that you see what it is, but in real life you'll use software
to run this test. The important thing is that you're able to interpret it, and
since you already know all about t tests, you know when to reject or fail to
reject the null. For example, let's say we're measuring the relationship
between two variables. And we have 25 participants. And let's say we do a
non-directional test at alpha equals 0.05. Let's say we get a t statistic equal
to 2.71. What do we conclude there is or there is not enough evidence to reject
the null because there is or is not a significant relationship between x and y.